qui a annoncé rondeau 2014 de façon très
originale en nous montrant une
échographie et pas n'importe quel
échographie 1 2 3 4 5
la maman porte des quintuplés l'image
idyllique pour un véhicule conçu pour
grandir avec la famille rien de bien
méchant donc dans cette pub qui en
outils simplement que sa nouvelle ronde
aux offres tout l'espace dont une très
grande famille a besoin
il est vrai qu'on peut y asseoir jusqu'à
7 personnes mais vérification faite
auprès de 400 cessionnaire nous avons
tous les imprudents global impossible
d'en ne fait quasi des cinq bébés de
l'échographie dans la ronde est
impossible siesta des plus réussies
siège pour enfant les parents se
qualifie de drones dont pourraient
véhicule légèrement plus grasse
transporter leurs marmailles